[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: You know, I
love chasing epiphanies.
I tell people that to
make art is a desire
to clothe inspiration,
right, to capture
the transient, fleeting
movements in which
the dots connect in a new way.
It's this idea that when we
are at our most creative,
we aren't even really creating.
We're channeling.
We're transcribing.
We are-- we are--
[LAUGH]
--conduits for something larger
than ourselves, to erupt,
to express itself through us.
We become a medium.
We become an instrument being
played by some other sentience.
You know, this sounds
like the musing--
the muses, of the madness, of
the Greek creative people, who
talked about being touched by
a hint of madness and something
erupting through them,
but not from them,
and no one is with them,
and it belongs not to them.
Creativity as a holy act,
creativity as divine grace,
it allows us to humble.
It allows us to succumb,
to surrender, to dive in,
to lose ourselves.
There's something kind
of beautiful about that.
There's something kind of
beautiful about getting out
of our own way, right,
which people talk
about when they talk about
flow states and creativity.
Oh, my god!
When that happens,
that is transcendence.
That is to be in ecstasy, to be
beside ourselves as something
comes through.
And that's, oh, that's
what we're chasing.
That's what we're
always, always chasing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]